Also die Kollegen, die auch CDs immer so im Auto einfach rumliegen haben.
Also Sonne ist wirklich der Tod, weil da eben auch sehr hoch energetische, kurzwellige Lichtstrahlen drin sind. Und besonders bei gebrannten Medien, da gibt es nämlich auch noch einen erheblichen Unterschied zwischen gebrannten und gepressten Medien, bei gepressten Medien, da wird ja im Grunde genommen ein Pressstempel in so ein Stück Alufolie reingedrückt. Und dieses Stück Alufolie ist natürlich wesentlich weniger empfindlich gegen Sonnenlicht als die Beschreibbaren. Bei den Beschreibbaren ist es ein sogenanntes Face-Change-Medium, was also sozusagen, was mit Hilfe eines Laserpulses zwischen der Amorphen- und Kristallinenphase hin und her geschaltet wird. Und da ist ja sozusagen, da ist gerade diese Lichtenergie dazu verwendet, um diese Phase umzuschalten. Und das bedeutet, dass man das natürlich da auch wieder rückgängig machen kann. Also gerade jetzt, jeder kennt ja auch wieder Beschreibbare Wesen. Und da muss es ja eine Möglichkeit geben, das auch umzukehren. Und da ist Sonnenstrahlung so was wie mit der Strohtflinte draufschießen.
Na, was würdest du denn für den Fall irgendwie jetzt tun, wenn du so eine DVD kriegst, die kaputt ist? Also die so abgeblättert ist oder wo sich die Schicht gelöst hat?
Also wenn die Schicht sich nur gelöst hat, ist das noch nicht der Tod. Wenn die Schicht komplett runter ist, dann würde ich sagen, dann ist das ein Fall, der sich nur noch lohnt, wenn das ein Staatsnotdatenträger ist. Also bei welchen wohl eine teilweise Ablösung oder Schrammen drauf sind, dafür haben wir Maschinen, mit denen wir die noch rotierend auslesen können. Sobald man sie sozusagen nicht mehr rotieren kann und sie rotierend auslesen, wird die Sache schnell sehr, sehr teuer.
Also ihr lest sie dann praktisch auf dem gleichen Weg aus, wie ein Player das auch machen würde, aber irgendwie die ganze Fehlerkorrektur macht ihr dann selber, oder?
Genau. Das ist die eine Methode und die andere Methode ist dann halt die mit der optischen Mikroskopie. Und da gibt es auch einige, kann man auch im Netz einige Forschungsarbeiten dazu finden. Da wird dann eben sehr langsam rotiert und wird quasi im Grunde genommen, in der Kamera werden kleine Stückchen von der Scheibe dann geknitzt. Und diese Bilder setzt man dann zusammen an der Stelle, wo sie zusammen gehören. Also die Probleme möge sich jeder selber ausmalen. Und dann muss man eben den sogenannten Read Channel, also sozusagen die Logik, die eigentlich aus den Pits und Lans hinten raus Userdaten macht, dann aus diesem Bild, praktisch durch einen Querschnitt durch das Bild, muss man eigentlich dieses Readback Signal simulieren und muss das dann durch einen simulierten Read Channel durchschieben und dann durch die simulierte Fehlerkorrektur hinten durchschieben und dann kommen mit viel Glück hinten Userdaten raus, aber das eben mit einer Bitrate, die, sag ich jetzt mal, im kommerziellen Bereich nicht sinnvoll ist.
Also das klingt ja schon so, als wenn optische Medien deutlich problematischer wären als magnetische zum Wiederherstellen.
Nein, das stimmt so auch nicht. Denn bei den magnetischen habe ich halt das Problem, wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise, es gibt ja so, die Substrate von diesen Festplatten sind zum Teil Glas und zum Teil Aluminium. Und wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel eine Glasplatte habe und die es gesplittert und ich habe nur noch eine Scherbe von der Festplatte, dann wird das auch sehr schnell sehr aufwendig. Dann muss ich im Grunde genommen das gleiche Verfahren anwenden, aber dann mit raster Sondenmikroskopie. Und das ist noch ein bisschen aufwendiger, als wenn man es, sage ich jetzt mal, mit einem hochvergrößernden Mikroskop.
Schaffen wir nicht in zwei Tagen.
Dimitri, jetzt hast du gehört, wie es geht. Viel Spaß beim Nachbauen. Alles Gute mit der Hobby-Tek von Fritz.
Eben gerade war das Thema RAID 5 bei euch.
Ich das von mir eigentlich auf RAID Z, von ZFS.
Also, besser oder schlechter?
Wähle zwischen zwei Gulen.
Das kann ich verstehen, aber ich sag's mal so. Wenn ich da irgendwie ein Problem mit zwei Datenträgern hätte, würde ich das ganze RAID verlieren? Oder könnte ich einfach sagen, Rebuild mir wirklich das, was du machen kannst und dass es eben weg ist, ist eben weg.
Also im Regelfall verliert man alles beim Ausfall von zwei Datenträgern bei RAID 5. Aber das ist halt, wenn du immer, wenn du die vorgesehene Redundanz, also wenn du mehr verloren hast als die vorgesehene Redundanz, ist im Regelfall dein Datenbestand hinüber. Und davor kann dich auch ZFS nicht schützen. Denn auch wenn ZFS die Redundanz nicht mehr hat, man kann es eben nur noch so lange berechnen, solange man noch genügend Information hat, aus der man es berechnen kann.
Alles klar, dann viel Spaß beim Nachbauen, Dimitri.
Bis denn, ciao.
Chaosradio auf Fritz, ihr merkt schon, es geht um Datenrettung, um Datenverlust und Datenträger und auch die Frage, wie kriege ich die Daten, die ich auf meinen Festplatten habe oder auf irgendwelchen Speichermedien, die mir wichtig sind, wie kriege ich die so sicher, dass die mir nicht irgendwann um die Ohren fliegen und dann plötzlich nicht mehr da sind. Ein paar Tipps hatten wir schon. Es fängt an bei so grundsätzlich kleinen Sachen. Bitte niemals am Kabel der Festplatte ziehen. Wenn die Festplatte rotiert, wenn das Ding umfällt, wird es nämlich hässlich. Legt eure CD's nicht in die Sonne, weil Sonnenlicht ist wie mit einer Schrotflinte da draufschießen. Und noch andere Sachen. Wir haben noch eine Wortmeldung von Björn. Guten Abend, Björn. Moin, von wo rufst du an?
Aus Hannover ruf ich an, meiner Kleinstadt daneben.
Aus Expo City Hannover?
Ja, ein bisschen nah dran, aber passt schon.
Alles klar, dein Computer war nicht nett zu dir?
Jo, das ist schon ein bisschen länger her. Das stammt aus der Zeit, wo 200 GB Festplatten noch richtig groß waren. Und zu dieser Zeit, wo 200 GB Festplatten noch richtig groß waren, konnte Windows XP ohne Service Pack 1 die noch nicht unterstützen. Da ging es nur bis zu 137 GB. Jo, und dann hab ich mein tolles Windows neu installiert auf der 80 GB Festplatte, die noch in dem Rechner war. Und nachdem die Installation dann vollendet war, nach dem ersten Start von Windows, fing Windows an die zwei Partitionen, die ich auf der 250 GB Festplatte hatte, zu reparieren.
Das klingt scheiße.
Ja, und das reparierte er dann so genial, dass ich, wenn ich ein Video von der einen Partition anklickte, eine MP3 von der anderen Partition hatte.
Ey, aber das ist immerhin ein kreativer Auswahl.
Das hätte ich Microsoft gar nicht zugetraut.
Guter Zufall, es geht dann auf 2.0.
Ich hab auch noch eine kreative MP3 aus dem Ausfall. Das ist ein Song von Nick Case. Da wird mittendrin einfach mal 3 Minuten lang Black Metal gespielt. Ich hatte dann halt verschiedene Shareware Festdatenrettungsprogramme durchlaufen lassen, die immer so 5 Stunden brauchten. Hab meine Schlafrhythmen dann immer drauf abgestellt, dass ich diese Zeit dann schlafe. Bin dann aufgestanden, hab gesehen, dass nichts gebracht hat. Hat das nächste Tools versucht, bin wieder zum Schlafen. Und das, was mich dann gerettet hat, war nach 5 Tagen der zweite Versuch mit Knoppix. Das konnte dann wieder lesen, war aber zu der Zeit, als Knoppix noch nicht USB 1.1 unterstützte und ich die Festplatten, den Inhalter irgendwo hin kopieren musste über USB, was auch ein Trick war, weil ich musste erst mal die 200 Gigabyte, das war damals viel, zusammen sammeln über Freunde, Bekannte und so weiter und so fort. Und das hat dann auch nochmal gut 2 Tage in Anspruch genommen, diese Dinge über USB 1.1 auf externe Festplatten zu kopieren.
Und ist diese Black Metal Einlage dabei wieder los geworden oder ist die dabei geblieben?
Nein, die MP3 hab ich heute noch auf der Platte.
Björn, was hast du daraus für das Jahr 2009 gelernt?
Kein Windows mehr.
Ist doch auch eine Ansage. Danke für den Anruf.
Jo, kein Problem.
Chaosradio auf Fritz 0331 70 97 110. Peter hat schon ein bisschen erzählt, wie Datenrettung im Detail funktioniert, wie das in den professionellen Datenrettungsfirmen läuft. Wir haben Christian am Telefon, der so ein ähnliches Problem anspricht. Hallo, Christian. Du hast...
Ja, ich habe ein Problem. Also ich bin auch immer der Ansprechpartner für Computerprobleme in meinem ganzen Bekanntenkreis. So, jetzt habe ich eine USB-Festplatte hier. Also was sie damit genau gemacht haben, das haben sie mir nicht gesagt. Ich gehe mal davon aus, sie haben sie während dem Betrieb runtergeschmissen. Also ich nehme es mal an. So, das war in USA, da sind Urlaubsbilder drauf. So, es ist so, die wären auch bereit, für eine Datenrettung was zu bezahlen. Also das Geld ist da mal sekundär. Jetzt haben die das beim Datenretter gehabt. Ich sage mal nicht den Namen, weil das darf mich hier wohl nicht sagen. Jetzt haben die da eine Mappe bekommen, mit Werbung drin, keine Ahnung, bla bla. Es steht hier ein Zettel dabei, steht irgendwie ganz klein drauf. Auf jeden Fall sowas Ähnliches. Media Damaged, Repairing Possible oder sowas Ähnliches. Also diese Datenretter in den USA war der Meinung, man kann das nicht mehr retten, und haben es denen wieder mitgekriegt. Die haben sie wohl auch aufgemacht. Das sieht man wohl. Meine Frage ist, kann man überhaupt noch irgendwas machen, oder kann ich es jetzt vergessen?
Also man kann dazu eigentlich sagen, man kann immer irgendwas machen. Das ist nur eine Frage des Preises. Es ist nur eine Frage, wie viel man dafür ausgeben will und wie lange man darauf warten muss. Das ist sozusagen mal die allgemeine Antwort. Die praktischere Antwort ist, dass mit jedem Eingriff im Regelfall das Problem schlimmer wird. Das heißt, man muss auf jeden Fall beim ersten Mal den, es ist das Beste, man erwischt beim ersten Mal den richtigen Datenretter, da eben, sag ich jetzt mal, solche Eingriffe die Platte weiter beschädigen können. Ich hab die Platte nicht gesehen und kann deswegen nicht sagen, ob das jetzt, kann das jetzt aus der Ferne nicht beurteilen, aber wenn ich ihnen raten sollte, würde ich sagen, sie können sich an einen weiteren Datenretter wenden und sie können dem am besten auch gleich sagen, wer da vorher die Finger drin gehabt hat. Die können sich natürlich alle untereinander auch. Und dann kann der ihnen eigentlich eine relativ gute Schätzung sagen, ob es noch einen Sinn hat da nochmal reinzuschauen.
Ich hab mal angerufen, bei einer Firma nennen wir sie mal Abzock, hab ich ihm angerufen und dann hat der gesagt, ja, Köpfe tauschen kann man gar nicht. Und das ist alles nur Humbug und die können die eh noch anschließen, mit dem Programm irgendwas durchgucken.
Also da haben sie offensichtlich eine unqualifizierte Firma erwischt.
Ja, ich sage ja, der Name Abzock steht dann wohl auch Programm. Also das heißt, man kann da auf jeden Fall was machen.
Natürlich, natürlich und ich hatte ja eben schon das Beispiel von der Scherbe eines Mediums mal erwähnt. Das ist im kommerziellen Bereich nicht sinnvoll, aber es gibt durchaus Kunden, die bereit sind, sehr viel Zeit und sehr viel Geld zu investieren, um herauszufinden, was auf dieser Scherbe denn gestanden hat. Und auch das ist machbar. Es ist eben nur nicht in einem, in ihrem Fall sind diese Methoden aus meiner Sicht wirtschaftlich nicht sinnvoll.
Na gut, Zeit spielt hier keine Rolle. Mir geht es nur darum, ist es sinnvoll, sich nochmal an jemanden zu wenden?
Auf jeden Fall würde ich sagen, ja, wenn Ihnen die Daten lieb sind, sollten Sie sich an einen seriösen Datenretter wenden und vielleicht auch nochmal die meistens irgendwas zwischen ein und 200 Euro für eine Diagnose investieren. Dann kriegen Sie auf jeden Fall, sag ich jetzt mal, kriegen Sie auf jeden Fall im Regelfall eine qualifizierte Antwort, was mit Ihrem Datenträger los ist und wo auch genau drin steht, was das Problem ist und wo auch genau drin steht, welche Methoden man anwenden müsste, um dieses Problem zu lösen und wo das dann auch mit den entsprechenden konkreten Preisen belegt ist.
Und wenn das alles nicht funktioniert, Christian, haben Sie immerhin noch die Legitimation, einen neuen Urlaub dran zu hängen, um neue Urlaubsvodos zu machen?
Und gut, wenn die Mädchen sein Freunde für die Zeit leiten, dann kann ich das machen.
Alles klar. Das klärt ihr untereinander. Danke dir für die Ahnung. Tschüss, Christian. Wir haben jetzt ganz viel über Festplatten gesprochen, über auch CDs, DVDs, also alles, was so rotiert, was irgendwie mit Schreib- und Lesegeräten funktioniert. Volker ist am Telefon. Der hat was zum Thema Flash-Speicher, was ja dann nicht so einfach geht. Hallo, Volker.
Ja, beziehungsweise Festplatte funktioniert auch, wenn die Festplatte mechanisch in Ordnung ist. Häufig genug hat man ja das Problem, dass die Daten dann auf dem Fallsystem im Eimer sind, weil das Dateisystem vollgelaufen ist, weil die Kamera ein etwas anderes Verständnis vom Fahrtfallsystem hat als der Datenspeicher oder ähnliches. Und dann ist halt mal der Speicher kaputt, lassen sich Fotos nicht auslesen oder sowas.
Na der Speicher ist ja nicht kaputt, also die Daten sind ja noch drauf.
Genau da setzen dann die entsprechenden Tools an, aber zumindest legt man in den Computer ein, die Fotokarte oder die Platte hängt man per USB dran und kann sie erstmal so nicht lesen.
Es gibt ja grundsätzlich zwei mögliche Arten von Schäden. Wir unterscheiden die immer in die zwei Klassen physikalischer Schaden und logischer Schaden. Genau und der Logische, der ist natürlich klar, dass es gibt eben auch Schäden, die durch wild laufende Betriebssysteme oder das Abziehen der Betriebsspannung im falschen Moment oder ähnliches entstehen können, sodass eben die Dateisysteme oder überhaupt die Verwaltungsstrukturen, die uns sagen, welcher Name denn zu welchen Sektoren welche Datei ergibt, dadurch in Mitleidenschaft gezogen werden können. Diese ganzen Probleme, die fassen wir zusammen unter logische Probleme, weil dort ja im Grunde genommen der Datenträger keinen technischen Defekt hat. Ich kann jeden Sektor des Datenträgers lesen, aber mein Betriebssystem oder mein Dateisystemtreiber kann daraus nicht mehr die ursprüngliche Struktur wiederherstellen.
Genau. Ich bin jetzt da teilweise im Forensikbereich aktiv. Was dann gemacht werden sollte, ist, nicht mit einem normalen Tool ranzugehen, also ich, Photoreq, Free Andelete, Andelete, irgendwelche Rescue Tools, da die meistens sofort wieder auf dem Ding rumschreiben. Das heißt, wenn die sich vertun, dann sind die Daten meistens noch besser durcheinander gewürfelt.
Wenn du sagst, du beschäftigst dich mit Forensik, dann wolltest du wahrscheinlich vorschlagen, dass man erstmal eine Imagekopie davon machen will.
Genau.
Diesen Vorschlag möchte ich mich gerne anschließen. Das ist eine sehr gute Idee. Überhaupt generell, wenn man jetzt so einen Datenverlust hat und man ist sich vielleicht nicht ganz sicher, ist es denn ein technisches Problem am Datenträger oder ist es ein logisches Problem, denn das ist manchmal gar nicht so leicht auseinanderzuhalten. Man stellt nur fest, das Betriebssystem zeigt dieses oder jenes Verzeichnis nicht mehr an. Das kann beide Ursachen haben. Dieser Rat ist sehr gut. Machen Sie eine Imagekopie von der Platte und wenn das an irgendeiner Stelle abbricht mit einer obskuren Fehlermeldung oder so etwas, dann gilt Regel Nummer zwei, Stecker raus, Finger weg.
wenn sich bei Festplatten entsprechend Geräusche melden.
Das hatten wir das hier vorhin schon gehabt. Wenn Geräusche sind wirklich irgendwie nichts, dann irgendwie ja, ich lass das mal noch zwei, drei Tage laufen.
Der Glaube an die technische Selbstheilung. Morgen wird's schon wieder gehen.
Dann ist die Kacke schon an Dampfen. Dann hat wirklich sofort Datenrettung einleitet, weil irgendwie jede Minute zählt dann.
Genau, jede Umdrehung kann mehr Späne produzieren.
Es gibt dann einmal die einfachen Tools, die Daten, die gelöscht sind oder nur teilüberschrieben sind, zumindest im Direktor verteilt überschrieben sind, wiederhergestellt werden können. Es gibt dann auch die etwas gründlicheren, die einfach dann nach entsprechenden Headern von Fotos, von typischen Office-Dokumenten suchen und dann versuchen von dort aus einfach die anschließenden Dateiblöcke bis zu einem sieht nach einem Ende aus wiederherzustellen.
Wobei ich dazu sagen muss, wenn man kein professioneller Datenretter ist, dann kriegt man viele Dateien, von denen nur ein paar funktionieren. Dann kann ich generell nur vor dem Einsatz von Tools warnen, es sei denn, dass die Daten nicht so wichtig sind. Es gibt ja auch so Sachen, wo man sich sagt, naja, wenn es weg ist, ist es auch nicht so schlimm, aber jetzt probiere ich nochmal. Dann kann man natürlich alles damit machen. Das ist keine Frage. Aber wenn es sich wirklich um unternehmenskritische Daten handelt, dann würde ich auch abraten überhaupt von irgendeinem Tool-Einsatz. Weil nämlich, selbst wir brauchen sehr lange, um herauszufinden, was diese kommerziellen Tools genau tun. Und ich sage einfach mal, dass der durchschnittliche Anwender das mitnichten überblicken kann. Ganz genau. Das ist auch eine Grundregel. Aber selbst bei den Imaging-Tools, da wird schon problematisch. Ich meine, jetzt viele Anwender sind auch aus meiner Sicht nicht in der Lage, ein 1 zu 1 Image von einer Festplatte herzustellen. Und auch da kann man eben Fehler machen. Da kann man auch beispielsweise Quelle und Ziel verwechseln. Und dann hat man seinen Datenträger mit Nullen überschrieben. Also man muss auf jeden Fall, wenn das wirklich was wert ist, dann soll man es den Profis überlassen. Und ansonsten, wenn man meint, es ist nicht so dramatisch wertvoll, dass man es selber probieren möchte, dann sollte man auf jeden Fall sehr viel Sorgfalt walten lassen beim Einsatz. Geht weder Tools und immer nur auf Kopien arbeiten.
Beziehungsweise...
Das ist ein guter Ratschlag.
Beziehungsweise, wenn ihr ein Tool habt, was irgendwie hier kostet nichts, probiert mal aus, kostenlose Download-Version, tralala, dann probiert das wirklich erst mal aus an irgendwas, wie Peter schon richtig gesagt hat, was wenn es dann weg ist, okay, nicht so dramatisch, aber nicht einfach irgendwo dran rumdoktern. Im Zweifelsfall macht ihr es nicht besser. Volker, danke für den Anruf.
Die Notschaft, die Volker gebracht hat, die war schon sehr richtig und wichtig, dass man ja, wenn der Datenträger nicht beschädigt ist, eigentlich immer eine hundertprozentige Kopie davon herstellen kann. Und das sollte man auch tun. Und auf dieser, also auf dieser sozusagen Tochterkopie kann ich ja drauf rumpferwerken, so viel ich will, ohne jetzt das Original zu beschädigen. Insofern ist das war das absolut der korrekte Hinweis.
Auf dem Image.
Ja.
Was sind denn physikalische Schäden an Flash-Speichern?
Physikalische Schäden an Flash-Speichern sind beispielsweise, wenn Flash-Zellen ausgefallen sind oder was auch häufig passiert ist, dass die Controller sich verirren, dass die halt also praktisch ihr Wear-Management aus dem Ruder läuft und dass sie selber nicht mehr wissen, wo sie die Sektoren hingetan haben. Und dass sie dann einfach sich praktisch totstellen, weil sie nicht mehr, weil sie die Zuordnung zwischen der Sektoradresse, die du dem Sektor gegeben hast und der Sektoradresse, die es tatsächlich in dem Speicherchip hat, nicht mehr wieder hinbekommen.
Kann man das dann nachträglich wieder rausfinden? Also wie rekonstruiert man die Daten dann?
Also wir machen das dann so, dass wir die Ships da einzeln rausholen, die dann auslesen, dann in eine Datenbank rein tun, also praktisch den Inhalt der einzelnen Ships. Und dann aufgrund der Kenntnisse, wie diese Controller arbeiten, die halt im Wesentlichen reverse-ingeniert sind. Wo man Glück hat, sind sie aus Datenblättern, wo man Pech hat, sind sie reverse-ingeniert. Und dann praktisch diese Zuordnung wieder aufbauen mit Hilfe von unseren eigenen Tools.
Wir sehen, Datenrettung ist ein weites Feld, was viele von euch auch interessiert. Hier die Leitungen sind knackervoll. Ich fürchte jetzt sogar schon um kurz vor halb zwölf, dass wir nicht alle rankriegen werden. Tim ist der nächste am Telefon, der ein Problem hat, was wir möglicherweise schon besprochen haben. Deswegen geht es eventuell schnell. Hallo Tim, guten Abend.
Ja, also ich hab eigentlich zwei Festplatten bei mir schon eine gewisse Zeit rumliegen. Das eine ist eine IBM Festplatte, da hatte ich schon mal im Internet nachgesehen. Das soll früher wohl ein Problemkind gewesen sein. Die Festplatte soll wohl dafür bekannt sein, dass die mehrmals den Geist aufgegeben hat. Das da, ja ich kann den Typ ja jetzt nicht sehen.
Na, steht ja drauf.
Na ja, hier steht so viel drauf.
DTLA 3040, irgendwas steht da. Genau, Modell.
EC 35L 120.
Ja genau, das ist der Nachfolger von der Platte.
Also die soll dafür worden sein.
Ich hatte die zwar immer mal so aufgemacht, also jetzt nicht richtig in die Innereien. Ich sage mal nur so, wo man in die Elektrik rankommt. Und dann hat es immer mal wieder so funktioniert, aber dann hat es irgendwann halt nicht mehr funktioniert.
Hast du denn deine Daten noch runtergekriegt, bevor es nicht mehr funktioniert hat?
Und die sind dir extrem wichtig?
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, die auf der zweiten Festplatte, das ist eine Samsung, die sind mir wichtiger, weil da sind die ganzen Fotos drauf von der Geburt meiner Kinder.
Das ist schwieriger als beim Urlaub, nicht? Geburten von Kindern sind schwieriger zu reproduzieren.
Deswegen, also, das ist natürlich sehr wichtig. Vor allen Dingen, wenn ich die nicht irgendwie noch runterkriege, kriege Chaos von meiner Frau.
Was wir alles nicht wollen.
Also bei der Samsung war das Problem, ich hatte dort hauptsächlich TrueCrypt-Container benutzt. Und komischerweise haben da ein, zwei Container als erstes den Geist aufgegeben, die konnten nicht mehr verbunden werden. Nein, das ist nicht korrekt. Die wurden verbunden, aber es konnte nicht auf die Daten zugegriffen werden. Ich hab also immer bei der Verbindung, die lief ganz normal über TrueCrypt, aber wenn ich auf die Daten zugreifen wollte, wurde mir eine Fehlermeldung ausgegeben. Und dann irgendwann hat die gesamte Festplatte den Geist aufgegeben.
Das hört sich auch wirklich nach einem physikalischen Problem an. Es hört sich nicht so an, als ob deine Crypto-Container da beschädigt sind, sondern wahrscheinlich hatte die Platte schon Lesefehler und darüber hat sich das TrueCrypt beschwert, weil es bestimmte Sektoren nicht mehr entschlüsseln konnte. Und ich fürchte, da bist du jetzt auch ein Fall für einen professionellen Datenretter geworden. Also sollte sowas mal wieder passieren, würde ich versuchen, die TrueCrypt-Container auf einen anderen Datenträger zu gucken.
Also was mich jetzt so ein bisschen verwirrt, ich hatte mir auch so Tools runtergeladen, ich weiß nicht was alles, unter anderem dann hier auch die System Rescue CD, was ja hier so eine Linux Live CD im Grunde eigentlich ist. Jetzt will ich mir das Programm nicht mehr einfallen, was auf Linux basiert, ist relativ bekannt, aber für Datenrettung.
Wahrscheinlich meinst du DD Rescue, also für den Kopierteil des Images, oder?
Naja, gut, auf jeden Fall werden mir da die Daten angezeigt und der rödelt auch los. Und er meldet mir, er hat das repariert, aber das Problem bleibt dasselbe wie vorher, nämlich dass ich auf die Festplatte nicht zugreifen kann.
Also repariert klingt schon mal ausgesprochen fischig, muss ich sagen. In dem Zusammenhang eine kaputte Festplatte per Software reparieren, das ist mir noch nie gelungen.
Dass die Daten wieder hergestellt sind.
Machen wir wirklich erstmal eine Kopie von der Platte, was wir schon öfter gesagt haben. DDoSQ zum Beispiel macht wirklich ein komplettes Image. Auf dem Image kannst du erstmal weitergucken, mit anderen Tools drauf rumspielen, weil da kann man auch nichts mehr kaputt machen. Man kann eben durch die Kopie immer wieder einspielen.
Das Problem ist, man kann durch das Kopieren auch noch mehr kaputt machen. Wenn es wirklich zu einem Familienstreit führt, würde ich mich doch lieber mal an einen Datenretter wenden. Und würde dann auch wirklich die Platte nicht mehr unter Strom setzen. Denn das, was du so erzählt hast, das hört sich eindeutig danach an, dass die Platte einen technischen Defekt hat. Und ich würde sogar mal aus der Hüfte geschossen sagen, einen Oberflächendefekt. Und der wird halt mit jeder Umdrehung der Platte schlimmer. Und den kannst du auch nicht beheben. Und auch nicht mit den Linux Voodoo Utilities. Denn das ist einfach ein Problem. Das ist wie wenn du mit der Zieglinge über die Schallplatte gefahren bist. Das kann man mit Software nicht in Ordnung bringen.
Genau, also mechanisches Problem, Hardwareproblem, nicht mit Software zu lösen.
Gut, aber vielleicht noch eine abschließende Frage. Wird vielleicht auch anderen interessieren. Es wird ja jetzt immer viel mit Extans, das Festplatten gearbeitet, die dann halt nur über USB angeschlossen sind. Ich hab jetzt auch einen Notebook. Das heißt also meine Rettungsversuche habe ich alle über USB Anschluss gemacht. Gibt es da Unterschiede? Geht das mit USB teilweise vielleicht überhaupt nicht?
Na ja, USB hat eigentlich nur einen einzigen Nachteil, nämlich, dass es schrecklich lahm ist. Also wann immer man USB durch eSata ersetzen kann, sollte man das tun. Weil USB ist einfach nur furchtbar lahm.
Also ansonsten hast du natürlich da auch einen ganz normalen IDE oder Sata-Controller in dem externen Gehäuse drin und irgendwie einen Umsetzer auf USB. Also sonst irgendwie eigentlich das Gleiche. Und im Zweifel kannst du halt immer die Platte aus dem Rahmen ausbauen und dann einen Desktop-Rechner einbauen und dann hast du irgendwie so wie es vorher.
Na gut, bei den aktuellen Konsumeprodukten kriegt man die Gehäuse kaum zerstörungsfrei auseinander. Es sei denn, man ist ein Meister des Plectrums.
Nee, also ich hab mir das immer selbst zusammengestellt. Das heißt, ich hab mir eine normale Einbaufestplatte geholt und dann extern die Gehäuse.
Also ich schwöre bei externen Gehäusen im Moment total auf ihr Saat da, weil das halt die gleiche Geschwindigkeit bringt wie eine interne Platte und ich trotzdem noch den Vorteil hab, dass ich die Platte separat vom Rechner habe.
Aber das USB-Netz, dass ich das nicht selber reparieren konnte wegen USB-Anschluss ist nicht möglich.
Das hat damit eigentlich nichts zu tun. Also ob du die Platte nun über Skasi oder über USB oder Buschtrommel anschließt, das macht doch keinen Unterschied.
Und im Zuge des allgemeinen Familienfriedens, wir wollen ja nicht, dass deine Frau dich vertrimmt. Sieh zu, dass die Platte bei Leuten in die Hände kommt, die wissen, was sie damit tun. Und befolge den Rat von Peter Frank. Lass den Strom von dem Ding, ja? Tschüss Tim. Nachrichten Wetterverkehr kommen gleich hier im Chaosradio auf Fritz und danach geht es weiter unter 0331 70 97 110.
Sie kommt für alle Fritz Freunde und deren Freunde. Und sie wird größer als alles bisher Dagewesene. So groß, dass man sie sogar vom Mond aus sehen könnte. Wenn er nicht so weit weg wäre. Und das hört man.
2, 5, 12.
Nachrichten.
Mit Benjamin Eüssel.
Am John Lennon Gymnasium in Berlin beginnt der Unterricht auch in Zukunft, die bisher um 8 Uhr morgens. Das hat die Schulkonferenz aus Eltern und Lehrern entschieden. Zuvor hatte schon die Mehrheit der Schüler dagegen gestimmt, die erste Stunde im Winter künftig erst um 9 Uhr beginnen zu lassen. Es war das erste Mal, dass Schüler in Berlin über den Unterrichtsbeginn abgestimmt haben. Die Bundesregierung will mehr Geld für die Abwrackprämie zum Kauf von neuen Autos ausgeben. Darauf haben sich Bundeskanzlerin Merkel und Vizekanzler Steinmeier geeinigt. Wie viel Geld zusätzlich bereitgestellt werden soll, steht noch nicht fest. Für die Abwrackprämie stehen bislang 1, 5 Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung. Wer ein neues Auto kauft und sein altes verschrottet, bekommt 2500 Euro. Die Kfz-Branche geht davon aus, dass das Geld schon in den nächsten Wochen aufgebraucht sein wird. Die Weltraum-Faire Discovery ist nach zwei Wochen an der internationalen Weltraumstation ISS auf dem Weg zurück zur Erde. Die sieben Raumfahrer sollen am Samstag landen. Die Besatzung hatte in drei Außeneinsätzen Sonnensiegel installiert und Wartungsarbeiten durchgeführt. In der Basketball-Bundesliga hat Albert Berlin mit 84 zu 69 gegen Ulm gewonnen. Damit hat Albert nur noch zwei Punkte Rückstand auf den Tabellenführer Oldenburg. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen an der Münde 1 Grad, Cottbus 2, Potsdam, Frankfurt, Wittenberger und Europin 3 und in Berlin auch 3 Grad. Die Temperaturen gehen in der Nacht auf bis zu minus 2 Grad runter. Dazu gibt es viele Wolken und besonders im Südwesten zeitweise etwas Regen oder Schnee. Morgen dann weiter stark bewölkt und immer wieder Regen in Richtung Uckermark soll aber auch öfter mal die Sonne rauskommen. Das Ganze bei maximal 9. Uns lieben keine Meldungen vor euch. Allen eine gute Fahrt.
Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr waren es mit Benjamin Eisel um 5 nach halb 12.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Dann Fritz im Raum Angermünde.
Berlin, die Zeitsprechstunden.
Willkommen zurück zum Chaosradio auf Fritz für die Statistiker und Freunde der Strichlisten. Wir sind im Teil 144. Peter Frank ist hier, Starbark ist da, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Wir reden heute über Datenverlust und vor allen Dingen auch Datenrettung. Haben schon ganz viel erfahren, was passiert, wenn die Festplatte nicht mehr die Daten ausspuckt, die da eigentlich drauf sind. Eure Fragen könnt ihr gerne am Telefon loswerden unter 0331 70 97 110. Die nächste Frage kommt aus Berlin von Jessie. Wunderbar und guten Abend. Wo ist das Problem?
Also mein Problem ist, dass ich, also ich muss von ganz vorne anfangen. Also ich arbeite als Bauzeichner und muss somit halt mit meinem Computer arbeiten und gehe nebenbei noch zur Schule und habe meinen großen Computer, also mein, wie nennt sich das? PC, genau, habe ich schon mal gelernt. Hab ich nie ans Internet angeschlossen, weil ich mir immer so dachte, okay in Ordnung kein Internet, da hast du deine Zeichnungen drauf, externe Festplatte, du bist gegen alles sicher.
Richtig.
Ja, bin ich nicht, weil ich musste jetzt meinen Desktop-PC komplett platt machen, weil er hat nämlich auf meinem Bildschirm gemacht, was er wollte und nicht das, was ich wollte. Und ich habe einen komischen Wurm in meinem Ding und auf meiner Festplatte, auf meiner externen Festplatte. Und meine externe Festplatte, so klug wie ich war, habe ich zu so einem Typen gebracht, der halt PC-Mensch sich nennt. Ja, und hab die dann erstmal, er hat gesagt, ja, ist in Ordnung, ist alles schick und ich musste ein paar Zeichnungen löschen, aber ist alles hier in Ordnung. Hab den an meinen Laptop angeschlossen, wo ich an jedem Programm drauf habe. Und dann hat er mir gesagt, dass da dieser Virus wieder drauf ist. Ich da wieder hingerannt, okay in Ordnung. Der Virus ist also, dieser Wurm ist immer noch drauf. Okay in Ordnung, ich mach's noch mal runter. Eine Woche gewartet, hab dieses Ding wieder angeschlossen und mein Laptop hat sich fast im Kreis gedreht, weil er wieder irgendeinen Wurm gefunden hat. Ich hab sie aber zwischendurch nirgendswo angeschlossen. Also sie war nirgendswo nur da. Und er hat mir auch gezeigt, also ich hab bei ihm ein Anzivieren-Programm und als ich wieder gekommen bin nach Hause, hab ich auch ein Anzivieren-Programm gemacht. Da war nichts. Ich hab sie ausgemacht und jetzt ist er wieder da. Was mach ich? Und wie krieg ich meine Zeichnung darunter? Ohne, dass ich wieder so vieler verliere. Und am besten so erklären, dass ich es auch verstehe.
Okay, die Antwort, die ist ein bisschen länger fürchtig und geht auch nicht so pauschal, denn... Also die Zeichnungen sind, dass die gute Nachricht ist, dass mit den Zeichnungen ist eigentlich gar kein Problem. Denn die Zeichnungen, die sollten eigentlich keinen ausführbaren Code enthalten. Insofern kann man die einfach auf einen anderen Datenträger kopieren und das auch ohne jede Gefahr im Allgemeinen. Also ich weiß ja nicht, welches Programm diese Zeichnung erzeugt hat, aber... AutoCAD hat nach meines Wissens keinen ausführbaren Code in den Zeichnungslateien drin. Das heißt, die kann man einfach woanders hin kopieren und da gibt es überhaupt keine Probleme. Der schwierigere Teil ist, was das mit diesem Wurm auf sich hat. Und... Da gibt es sehr viele Möglichkeiten. Es kann zum Beispiel... Eine Möglichkeit ist, dass irgendeine Datei auf dieser externen Festplatte eine Beitfolge oder praktisch eine Signatur hat, die ein bestimmtes Antiviren-Programm als Schadsoftware erkennt, obwohl es gar keine ist. Das wäre dann der false positive Fall. Das kann passieren, gerade wenn Sie sagen, dass der andere Mensch mit seinem Antiviren-Programm diesen offenbar nicht finden konnte. Dann kann es natürlich weiterhin sein, also diese Schadsoftware-Programme sind zum Teil so intelligent, dass sie sich halt möglicherweise auf Ihrem Laptop eingenistet haben. Und dass das unter Umständen erst dann in Erscheinung tritt, wenn Sie diesen Datenträger anschließen, aber eigentlich die ganze Zeit da ist. Also es gibt viele verschiedene Möglichkeiten.
Ich hab bei meinem Freund, der hat ja auch mal noch ein Laptop, und der ist jetzt monatelweise immer in Bayern, und der hat ihn auch angeschlossen. Bei ihm hat sich das auch überschlagen. Der ist aber nie wieder neu. Den hat er vor drei Monaten gekauft, und seitdem war er nie wieder hier.
Also hast du irgendeine Ekelhaftigkeit auf dieser Platte?
Richtig, aber die hab ich nicht nur auf meiner Platte. Ich bin der Meinung, ich hab ja ein kleines bisschen Ahnung, dass auf meinem großen desktop PC in dieser DOS-Abteilung dieser Wurm sitzt.
Wir können die Sache ein bisschen abkürzen, um dich wieder aus dem Würgegriff des Wurms zu befreien. Einen sauberen Rechner nehmen, alle Zeichnungen runter kopieren, Platte neu formatieren und die Zeichnungen wieder drauf kopieren. Dann kann der Wurm eigentlich nicht mehr drauf sein.
Also ich würde auch sagen, du hast den Desktop nicht am Netz gehabt, aber dadurch, dass du die Platten umgesteckt hast, ist das auch ein Verbreitungsweg für den Wurm. Das heißt, der ist dann halt nicht über das Netz gekommen, sondern über deine ex-NFS-Platte. Und der wird halt garantiert auch da drauf sein. Und wenn das Tool es nicht gefunden hat und ihn richtig runtergelöscht hat, dann ist er halt irgendwie beim nächsten Mal dann auch wieder drauf. Das heißt irgendwie...
Wobei man dazu noch sagen muss, dass eine grundsätzliche Einschränkung von Virenscannern ist, dass die grundsätzlich nur das erkennen, was sie kennen. Und dass dort draußen noch wesentlich mehr Schadsoftware unterwegs ist, als das, was die Virenscanner erkennen. Und somit ist dieses ganze Konzept eigentlich grundsätzlich schon lückenhaft. Und das ist aber, denke ich, Material für eine weitere Sendung. Insofern können wir die hier erst mal nur diesen praktischen Tippen geben.
Also wenn du wirklich sicher gehen willst, um das was das Peter gerade gesagt hat, wirklich die Daten, also wirklich die Zeichnungen separat runter kopieren, alles platt machen, wieder rausspielen, dann solltest du sicher sein.
Und im Zweifelsfall aus der externen Platte einfach eine schöne Blumenbank machen und wieder neue zulegen, so dramatisch, weil das sind dir halt zu teilen.
Als Briefbespieler wird sie für sich auch ganz gut machen.
Jesse, vielen Dank, wir hoffen wir haben geholfen. Und es gibt noch ein Problem von John. Hallo John, guten Abend.
Grüß dich, was ist los? Ich hatte, ich merke jetzt live, und da geht das Gespräch in die Richtung. Und zwar in die Richtung logische Schäden. Weil da unterhalte ich natürlich ein Virus auch, oder ein Boom auch einordnen. Das Problem am Anfang wurde relativ viel über Testplattenrücksicherung und Testplattenoperatur geredet, für den Fall, dass die Festplatte wirklich kaputt ist. Was allerdings jetzt in meiner Meinung nach ein bisschen zu kurz gekommen ist, dass ein Rade 5 nichts vor einem logischen Schaden schützt. Also kann ich noch so viel Rade Level in mein Festplattensystem einbauen, wenn ich einen Boom habe, der meine Festplatte befähigt, oder meine Daten beschädigt, da werden die natürlich auf alle anderen Platten in diesem Rade mit repliziert, diese Schäden.
Ja, man kann eigentlich, also ein Rade ist ja eigentlich nur die Abstraktion für eine Festplatte, die aus mehreren Festplatten besteht und die ein gewisses Maß an Redundanz drin hat. Ein Rade verhält sich ja im Grunde genommen gegenüber dem Betriebssystem genauso wie eine einzelne Festplatte. Das heißt also da braucht man dann aus logischer Sicht keinen Unterschied machen, ob das eine einzelne Festplatte oder ein Rade ist.
Und von der Seite würde mich interessieren, ob es da Vorschläge gibt, zum Beispiel wie und mit welchen Tools ich überprüfen kann, ob die Daten auf meinen Sicherungskopien also es muss nicht immer unbedingt ein laufendes Rade-System sein, es könnte auch mal eine USB-Festplatte sein, auf die ich jetzt in meiner Naivität gigabyteweise an Daten schaufe. Und irgendwann geht die eine von den Platten kaputt, da weiß ich, ich habe irgendwo noch eine andere Platte liegen, möchte von dieser Platte die Daten wieder runterholen. Und es stellt dann fest, dass ich ein total chaotisch unorganisierter Mensch bin und gar nicht mehr weiß, welche Daten jetzt überhaupt noch wo liegen. Und mir deswegen auch nicht hundertprozentig sicher sein kann, dass die Daten auf dieser USB-Festplatte jetzt überhaupt noch konsistent sind.
Na gut, also gegen Chaos im Kopf kann die Technik kaum helfen, das ist ganz klar.
Das Chaos steigt ja mit den steigenden Datenträgerkapazitäten, mit den entsprechenden Mengen an Daten, die dann auf die Festplatten drauf kopiert werden. Und wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel einen logischen Fehler auf einer Platte habe, aber diesen Fehler immer munter resiziere, auf meine ganzen Backups, und dann irgendwann mal das Backup von 2002 wegschmeiße, wo ich der Meinung bin, irgendwann ist mein Zernschrank voll, dann hab ich natürlich nie gemerkt, dass meine superschönen Bildsammlungen alle schon die eine oder andere, ich würde das mal so ein Kratzer haben.
Da gibt es zwei relativ kurze Antworten drauf. Die eine Antwort ist, dass das ein System, wie man nennt es, das Problem von Backups ist, dass wenn man sie wegschmeißt, dass man sie dann nicht mehr hat. Und die zweite Antwort ist, dass die einzige Möglichkeit, ein Backup zu verifizieren, das Zurückspielen und Durchprobieren aller einzelnen Dateien ist, womit die andere Frage dann glaube ich auch beantwortet ist.
Wobei, die Frage nach dem Tool noch offen wäre. Was wäre jetzt die praktische Variante, wenn ich eine 200 GB auf 500 GB Festplatte habe, mit entsprechend vielen Backups, mach ich immer, mach immer brav eine Spiegelung oder eine Synchronisation auf eine zweite USB-Platte?
Na dann überprüfst du nachher, ob die Daten wirklich konsistent sind, also ob sie miteinander übereinstimmen. Also kannst du einen Hash auf die eine Platte machen, einen Hash auf die eine weite Platte machen, einfach vergleichen. Wenn sie übereinstimmen, hast du auf jeden Fall eine 1 zu 1 Kopie gemacht. Und irgendwie alles andere, was später passiert, hast du dann halt irgendwie nicht im Griff. Also wenn irgendwie die Bits umkippen, weil du die Platte irgendwie in einem Sonnenlicht gelagert hast, dann kannst du irgendwie halt auch mit irgendwelchen Tools nichts mehr irgendwie reißen.
Und Grundvoraussetzung Nummer eins ist, Chaos im Kopf erstmal sortieren.
Na ich glaube, was du meintest, ist, wie kannst du sicherstellen, dass die Dateien, die du dort weggespeichert hast, tatsächlich einen Sinn ergeben? Und die Antwort darauf ist, das kannst du nur feststellen, indem du sie individuell überprüfst, ob sie einen Sinn ergeben.
Das heißt, in der Konsequenz müsste ich dann versuchen, die Ordnung vorher zu schaffen und weniger Daten...
Also das würde auf jeden Fall... Ordnung vorher schaffen macht auf jeden Fall weniger Arbeit als Ordnung hinterher schaffen.
Ja, auch John wird dieses Wochenende wahrscheinlich eine ganze Zeit vor seinem Rechner setzen und das alles wieder sortieren.
Ich hatte unter anderem auch das Problem, weil so einfach ist es mit der einfachen Synchronisation über zwei Platten auch nicht, wenn man halt über mehrere Plattengenerationen wächst.
Ich verstehe dein Problem.
Wenn man mit einer Gigabyte Platte anfängt, dann immer auf eine 250er, dann irgendwo liegt da noch eine 500 Gigabyte Platte rum.
Du glaubst gar nicht, wie ich dein Problem verstehe, weil ich habe so viele Notebooks saved 2004, 2005 auf meinen Rechnern zu liegen. Schmeiß die Daten einfach weg und wenn du nicht weißt, was drauf ist, dann hat es einfach keinen Sinn.
Es ist manchmal noch ganz befreiend, sich von Dingen zu trennen, John. Sag einfach Ja dazu.
Oder warte auf deinen nächsten Platten, dann wird für dich entschieden.
Probier es aus, du bist ein neuer Mensch.
Da habe ich vielleicht noch eine Sache zum Thema.
Dann mach schnell, weil es rennt jetzt wirklich ein bisschen die Zeit weg.
Ganz schnell, einer der vorhergehende Anrufer hat gesagt, er sichert seine Daten auf TrueCrypt-Containern. Das ist eine nette Sache. Also links sollte man die Header der TrueCrypt-Container mitsichern, weil in den ersten, glaube ich, vier Kilobyte oder so stehen die Schlüsse drin. Und wenn die weg sind, dann nutzen einem die restlichen wie viel Gigabyte das auch immer sind, nichts mehr.
Das ist wohl selbstverständlich, dass du alle Daten sicherst.
Genau, bei allen verschlüsselten Lösungen immer die Header-Dateien und die Keys sichern. Oder so einen Keyback abmachen, so ein Reversal.
Das ist ein guter Tipp, ist nicht in allen Fällen notwendig. Ich würde sowieso sagen, dass Full Device Encryption auf jeden Fall besser ist als irgendwelche Container. Aber auf jeden Fall, guter Rat, sichert die Schlüssel mit. Und ein zweiter guter Rat, verschlüsselt eure Platten.
Ja, Chaosradio geht langsam so ein bisschen im Ende entgegen. Wir haben jetzt ganz viel über Datenrettung und Datensicherung gesprochen und Daten wieder zurückholen. Aber es gibt ja auch Daten auf Platten, wo ich sage, die möchte ich nicht mehr, die haue ich jetzt weg. Ich werde diese Daten auf der Platte löschen. Das gibt unterschiedliche Theorien, was dazu zu machen sind. Wie oft zum Beispiel müssen die Sektoren auf so einer Festplatte überschrieben werden, bis das wirklich weg ist? Also wie lösche ich meine Festplatte so, dass auch du, Peter, da nicht mehr noch irgendwelche Sachen drauf findest?
Also da gibt es auch eine sehr einfache und eine sehr schwierige Antwort drauf.
Dann möchte ich erst die einfache.
Die einfache Antwort ist, es genügt, wenn du dafür sorgen möchtest, dass ich einen Sektor nicht mehr lesen kann, dann genügt es, diesen einmal zu überschreiben mit einem Inhalt deiner Wahl. Also wir reden jetzt von modernen Festplatten. Lass uns jetzt nicht in die Oldschool-Geschichte. Wenn du heute eine Festplatte aus dem Laden holst und du hast sie einmal überschrieben, dann sind die Daten weg.
Also früher war es ja, weißt du, das gibt ja die mehr, dass man irgendwie 35 mal überschreiben sollte oder irgendwie alte Tools haben auch immer einen Counter, wie oft man die Daten überschreiben hat. Das war aus dem Grund, dass halt früher die Platten mit so großen Toleranzen gearbeitet haben, dass halt irgendwie nicht auf dem gleichen auf dem gleichen Spur praktisch die Daten geschrieben wurden, sondern halt immer leicht versetzt. Das heißt, wenn du sie einmal überschrieben hast, konnte man eventuell durch die Restmagnetisierung auf den Spur daneben halt um die Daten noch auslesen und wieder rekonstruieren. Das ist irgendwie halt heute nicht mehr so, weil einfach die Motoren, die ganzen...
Na ich glaube, ich kann es erklären. Also die Schreibtichte ist so weit so weit gestiegen, dass die Spuren standardmäßig im Normalbetrieb der Platten schon leicht überlappen. Das heißt also, dass im Grunde genommen die Spur rechts die Spur links schon ein bisschen überschreibt und die Spur links die Spur rechts schon ein bisschen überschreibt. Und dadurch gibt es dazwischen praktisch nichts mehr und ich könnte jetzt auch ganz tief in die Theoriekiste greifen und von 747 Kurven und was weiß ich, was alles reden. Dafür haben wir nicht mehr die Zeit heute, deswegen lassen wir das.
Kannst du auf den Kongress mal machen.
Tatsache, es jedenfalls einmal überschreiben reicht, aber jetzt muss ich leider auch die schlechte Nachricht noch mit dazu bringen. Die schlechte Nachricht ist nämlich, dass ich nur sehr schwer entscheiden kann, welchen physikalischen Sektor ich denn nun überhaupt mit meinem Schreibzugriff erreicht habe. Denn diese Platten sind heute sowas von intelligent, da sind teilweise leistungsfähige Prozessoren auf den Platten-Elektroniken als in dem Rest von dem Rechner. Und die tun da allerhand. Und was die eben auch tun, ist, dass die die Sektor umnummerieren. Das heißt also, wenn ich sage, ich beschreibe jetzt den Sektor 23, dann kann ich ohne tiefste Kenntnis dieser Controller und deren Firmware eigentlich nicht vorhersagen, wo dieser Sektor auf der Platte, oder noch schlimmer ist es bei Solid-State-Discs, wo dieser Sektor, in welchem Chip der Solid-State-Discs dieser Sektor eigentlich landet.
Also ist es inzwischen auch bei Festplatten so?
Es ist auch bei Festplatten so, ja. Es ist bei Festplatten nicht ganz so schlimm, da ist die Zuordnung zwischen der LBA, also der logischen Blockadresse, und dem tatsächlichen physikalischen Speicherort auf dem Medium etwas dichter als bei Solid-State-Discs. Aber sie ist nicht ohne tiefere Kenntnis des Controllers und seiner Firmware vorhersehbar. Und das Problem ist also nicht, wie oft überschreibe ich den Sektor, sondern die Frage ist, habe ich ihn überhaupt getroffen? Und diese Frage ist wirklich, da könnten wir jetzt noch eine Extrasendung machen, wie überschreibe, also wie stelle ich fest, ob ich oder kann ich überhaupt feststellen, welchen Sektor ich denn nun wirklich physikalisch überschrieben habe. Tatsache ist jedenfalls, es macht überhaupt gar keinen Unterschied, ob ich diesen Sektor einmal oder eben diese vorgeschlagenen, weiß ich nicht, hundertmal nicht überschrieben habe. Das Ergebnis ist das gleiche, er ist noch da.
Okay, das heißt, die Alternative ist dann halt wirklich die Gausser, also wirklich mit elektromagnetischem Puls so auf die Daten, auf die magnetischen Ausrichtungen einzuhauen, dass wir sich dann...
Das ist ja kein elektromagnetischer Puls, also wir wollen es ja nicht übertreiben, das ist einfach nur ein Magnetfeld. Also man kann natürlich mit einem Magnetfeld, was deutlich höher als die Koalzitivfeldstärke des Mediums ist, und jetzt wollen wir auch nicht zu tief in die Physik gehen, kann man die Ausrichtung, kann man die Ausrichtung dieser magnetischen Oberfläche löschen. Aber auch das ist nicht so einfach, denn auch das kann ich ja letztlich wirklich nur vorhersehbar tun, wenn ich das Medium aus der Festplatte ausbaue, denn sonst habe ich eine ganze Menge Metalle dazwischen, die zu einer Veränderung des eingestrahlten Magnetfeldes führen, zu einer Abschwächung oder auch zu einer Umlenkung. Und so ist es, es ist wirklich eine sehr schwierige Thematik, ich denke, wir sollten da bei dem, also wir sollten da bei dem, bei dem überschreiben bleiben, also ein, ein für Privatverhältnisse vernünftiger Weg, eine Platte vor dem Weiterverkauf über eBay oder der Entsorgung oder was weiß ich zu löschen, also ein vernünftiger und machbarer Weg ist, bei einer Festplatte einfach ein DD von Def Zero auf dem, auf Sektor 0 bis letzten, bis letzte LBA der Festplatte. Und dann kann man zumindest sagen, habe ich einen großen Teil der Daten, den größten Teil, beseitigt, so dass ich mir keine Sorgen machen muss, dass da irgendjemand das wiederfinden wird. Nur da liegt eben die Tücke im Detail. Es werden einzelne Sektoren infolge des Defect-Managements ausgelagert, die erreiche ich dann natürlich nicht mehr, weil ich sie als, weil die gar keine LBA-Adresse mehr haben. Also kann ich sie vom Rechner aus gar nicht mehr adressieren. Es gibt so Spielereien wie die sogenannte Host-Protected Area oder eben Arta Setmax. Also wer sich den Arta-Standard durchliest, der wird da die lustigsten Dinge feststellen, dass man da auch praktisch per Arta-Kommando die Festplatten in verschiedenen, also verkleinern kann, praktisch sizeen kann, sodass man einen Teil praktisch restlos vor dem Controller verbirgt. Den wird man natürlich damit auch nicht erreichen, denn da kann Linux oder DD auch nichts dran tun. Das lässt sich nur mit speziellen Arta-Kommandos wieder freisetzen und so weiter und so fort. Aber wenn ich den Sektor erreicht habe bei einer modernen Festplatte und habe ihn überschrieben, und zwar meine ich jetzt den Sektor hardwaremäßig auf dem Medium. Ich meine jetzt nicht den Sektor, den ich denke, der die LWA-Adresse hat, die ich angegeben hat. Also wenn ich den einmal überschrieben habe, dann ist der nicht mehr wieder herzustellen.
Aber soll die Grundaussage schon halt irgendwie löschen oder einfach nur wirklich als löschen markieren, bzw. formatieren, reicht halt nicht aus, weil man wirklich die Daten mindestens einmal überschreiben, dass sie halt sicher weg sind.
Ich muss sie vollständig überschreiben, damit sie weg sind. Das ist richtig.
Wie sieht es bei SSD oder bei CDs aus?
Bei SSD ist da ein ganz großes Problem, denn die Aufgabe des SSD-Controllers ist eben möglichst wenig Daten an die gleiche Stelle zu schreiben, weil die Flashzellen eine begrenzte Lebensauer haben. Das heißt, jeder SSD-Controller versucht, die Schreibzugriffe gleichmäßig auf alle Flashzellen zu verteilen. Und wie macht er das? Sagen wir mal, ich schreib jetzt 100.000 Mal den Sektor 0 neu. Na was wird der machen? Intern in seiner kleinen Organisation da drinnen, schreib ich, wenn ich das erste Mal, ich nehme jetzt einfach mal ein doofes Beispiel, ich schreib das erste Mal den Sektor 0, dann wird er den Hardware Sektor 0 überschreiben. Jetzt schreib ich denselben Sektor nochmal, wieder Sektor 0, dann denkt er, ups Sektor 0 hab ich gerade geschrieben, jetzt muss ich einen anderen nehmen, nehmt er Sektor 1. Wenn ich jetzt 100.000 Mal geschrieben hab, dann hab ich jetzt praktisch 100.000 Kopien dieses Sektors in 100.000 Flash Sektoren dupliziert. Das heißt, ich hab jetzt 100.000 Kopien des selben Sektors in meinem Flash.
Und so richtig gewonnen hast du nichts.
Das heißt, hier ist überschreiben also deutlich kontraproduktiv. Weil beim überschreiben, im Grunde genommen, ich überhaupt erst wieder Sektoren nimm, die schon mal gebraucht sind, wenn er alle, die noch nicht gebraucht sind, zu Ende verbraucht hat.
Das heißt wirklich auch auf der Hardware-Ebene zerstören, also mit dem Hammer raufhauen oder?
Ja, naja, auch das muss nicht unbedingt helfen. Ich meine, ich kann den Chip auch auseinander holen.
Wie macht man es denn wirklich ordentlich?
Und rebonden. Also, okay. Also wenn man es wirklich ordentlich machen will, also da kann ich dir jetzt keinen praxistauglichen Tipp geben. Ich kann dir nur sagen, wenn du jetzt die Flashchips natürlich rausholst und du fängst an, die Planes direkt auf dem Chip zu eräsern, dann kannst du natürlich sicher sein, dass sie weg sind.
Das ist ein bisschen viel Aufwand.
Aber durch die Schnittstelle hindurch gibt es keine sichere Möglichkeit, eine SSD zu löschen. Das ist, glaube ich, das ist das, was man so rausgeben kann für die Leute, die es wissen wollen. Also SSD löschen per Software nein.
Und CD ist Mikrowelle?
Mikrowelle ist ziemlich effizient bei CD.
Aber danach nicht mehr essen. Wir kommen so ein bisschen zum Ende der Sendung. Wir könnten noch stundenlang weitermachen. Wie Peter schon sagte, es gibt einige Fachgebiete, wo wir da noch weitere Sendungen dazu zaubern wollen. Vielleicht zum Abschluss noch mal ganz kurz die drei wichtigsten Sachen, die wir uns alle ins Hausaufgabenheft schreiben zum Thema Wie kriege ich meine Daten sicher? Wenn wir über Festplatten reden, Peter.
Die drei wichtigsten Sachen, naja, also...
Kopieren, also Sicherheitskopie machen, auslagern, also nicht zu Hause lagern, sondern wirklich an einem anderen Ort auch, weil es irgendwie Feuer gibt.
Wenn die Festplatte Geräusche macht, lasst den Strom weg davon.
Genau, also das, ja, genau. Wenn es ein Physikale, also wenn es ein logisches Problem ist, erst ein Image davon anfertigen, auf einer anderen Platte und da drauf rumspielen. Wenn sich dabei ein Problem herausstellt bei diesen Imagen, dann ist es wahrscheinlich ein physikalisches Problem. So wie auch wenn die Platten Geräusche machen und dann kann man im Regelfall selber nichts mehr tun. Dann braucht es einen Reihenraumlabor und dann, wenn einem die Daten lieb sind, muss man sofort den Strom abschalten.
Das war Chaosradio auf Ritz, Teil 144. Vielen Dank Peter, vielen Dank Starbuck, dass ihr hier wart. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz, hier geht es gleich weiter mit den Kollegen vom Night Flight. Max, Smart und Konsorten sind am Start. Werden euch jetzt hier biet zum die Ohren hauen, dass die Wände wackeln. Wir hören uns spätestens in vier Wochen wieder zum nächsten Chaosradio, die Sendung nochmal hören. Geht natürlich als Podcast entweder auf fritz.de oder aber auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Bis demnächst. Tschüss, machts gut.